THIS LOVELY EVENING THANK YOU
FOR ALL BEING HERE.
AND WE HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
ON SPECIAL ORDER FOR BILLS I
HAVE BEEN PLACED ON CONSENT.
THIS LEAVES US WITH ELEVEN BILLS
TO BE PRESENTED THIS EVENING
[inaudible]
OUR FIFTY WE WILL GO AHEAD GIVEN
THAT WE HAVE NO QUORUM AT THE
MOMENT-- WILL ALLOW BILLS JUST
TO BE.
GO AHEAD AND AND PRESENTED.
AND THE MESSAGE.
SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IF YOU
DON'T MIND COMING ON UP AND
PRESENTING ON YOUR BILL.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SO I'M PRESENTING AB EIGHT
NINETEEN WHICH BUILDS ON
LEGISLATION THAT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND THIS IS
THE CONTINUED CARE REFORM.
THE COMMITMENT WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND MYSELF WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE CONSTANTLY IMPROVING
IMPLEMENTATION AROUND THE COULD
TEAM OF CARE FOR ME.
THIS IS AS YOU KNOW THE THE
REFORM THAT IS MOVING AWAY FROM
GROUP HOMES AND INTO SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC SETTINGS
FOR KIDS.
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. TO
GET THEM READY FOR
INDIVIDUALIZED PLACEMENTS.
WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON THIS YEAR
IS ADJUSTING THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS WE'RE MAKING
SOME CHANGES IN THE INTENSIVE
SERVICES FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT?
WE'RE AUTHORIZING TRIBAL
APPROVED HOMES FOR TO ACCESS
FOSTER FAMILY HOME.
AND ALLOWING US TO CONTINUE TO
CLAIM FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THAT FOR
CAN GAP.
WE'RE ALSO MAKING SEVERAL
CHANGES SO THAT WE WILL BE READY
FOR THE FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT A FEDERAL ACT
ENSURING THAT STATE LAW
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW ALIGNS.
WITH THOSE PROVISIONS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES I DO HAVE SOMEONE HERE
FROM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
AND IF NOT [inaudible]
ASPERA -- WITNESSES AND SO FORTH.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SURE.
HE EXPLAINED THE THE SOMEBODY
EXPLAIN THE WE'RE GOING FROM.
TWO TO THREE KIDS AND NINE A AS
OF C. FACILITY.
YEAH THERE'S SEVEN OH WHAT'S THE
KIND OF LOGIC.
WELL IT THERE WAS SOME OF THEM
THE INCREASES WERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COULD HAVE.
KIDS WHO ARE RELATED SO IN THE
SAME FAMILY AS A SIBLING ISSUE
THE S. HAVING ISSUES AND SERRA.
IT ALSO WOULD ADDRESS SITUATIONS
WHERE THE DETAILS FOR SOAPS.
THIS IS CHARACTERS WITH A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND FRENCH T. FOR
CONTINUING CARE REFORM -- IT
ALSO WOULD ADDRESS CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THE CHILD HAS A PRIOR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FAMILY --
IN ADDITION TO A SIBLING
RELATIONSHIP WHICH IS NOT
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
ALLOWED.
THE THREESOME MAX THREE WOULD BE
THE MAX FOR IOS OF SEA.
LEVEL.
BUT I DO ACTUALLY HAVE A HAND
OUT IF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
WE'VE COULD HAVE CHARTED OUT TO
MAKE IT REALLY CLEAR.
IF THERE'S LESS THAN THREE AYE
SFC THEN YOU COULD HAVE OTHER
NON AYE AND SIXTY SO THAT'S THE
MAX BUT IF YOU SEAL ON THE YOU
DON'T THINK THREE CAN BE MANAGED.
MAYBE THEY HAVE TO REAL SEVERE
ONE EVEN.
ONE YOU CAN JUST LEAVE IT AT
CORRECT.
THE COUNTY WOULD STILL PROVIDE
AN ASSESSMENT OF THE TO THE
FAMILY'S ABILITY TO CARE FOR
THAT NUMBER OF CHILDREN
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THAT'S ALL I NEED TO KNOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO A CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE OKAY SO ARE GIVEN THE WE
HAVE NO FORMA THE TRAMMELL.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME OKAY.
SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
CALL ME.
OKAY UP NEXT IS A. B. THIRTEEN A
ONE FILE ITEM. TO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WELCOME
PLEASE FEEL FREE.
TO AGAIN AND AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
OH ONE RELATED PRIVATE ADOPTION
FUNDING.
OTHER PRIVATE AGENCY ADOPTION
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS PART.
IT WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR TO HELP INCENTIVIZE
PRIVATE ADOPTION FOR CHILDREN.
WOULD OTHERWISE REMAIN IN FOSTER
CARE. TO GET HIM OUT OF FOSTER
CARE GIVEN ADOPTION.
CURRENTLY PRIVATE ADOPTION
AGENCIES ARE REIMBURSED UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHILD.
FOR COSTS WOULD OTHERWISE BE
UNREIMBURSED WHEN AGE HE'S
RECRUIT AND FIND ADOPTIVE
FAMILIES.
PARKS GRACIOUSNESS AT AS A STATE
WE'VE SEEN MAJOR CHANGE WITH THE
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT CANOED
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
MY COLLEAGUE PERCENT WHO JUST --
ALLUDED.
TO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
RESTRUCTURE THE PART PROGRAM TO
HELP CONTAIN COST OF THE
CALORIES.
ALL THE SAME TIME PRESERVING
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING -- A MUCH
YOU TO FUND MIXES FOR PRIVATE
ADOPTION AGENCIES WHO THE
CRITICAL WORK.
OF FINDING PERMIT FAMILY
PLACEMENTS FOR CHILDREN IN NEED.
UNDER THIS BILL COUNTIES WILL
TAKE ON RESPONSE REFER COMPTON
ADOPTION AGENCIES. FOR THEIR
OTHERWISE WE UNREIMBURSED COSTS
AND FIND IN PLACE TO TRAVEL THE
FAMILY.
WELL SHOULD IN SOME OF THE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE DOWN THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
THIS WILL ALSO GIVE COUNTY SOME
PROVIDERS MORE FREEDOM FOR
REIMBURSEMENT.
A COST FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES OF
PERMANENCY PLACEMENT AND NOT
JUST THE LIMITED ADOPTIONS COST.
RECENT AMENDMENTS AGREED TO BY
ALL STAKEHOLDERS ESTABLISH A
STATE WIDE RATE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT.
AND LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES THE
PROGRAM ACCOUNTING FUNDING --
AND I AM CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS I HAVE
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS.
AS YOU MOVE THE BILL ALONG TO
ENSURE A SMOOTH TRANSITION.
A TO THIS NEW FUNDING APPROACH
AS WELL AS BRING CERTAINTY OF
FUNDING FORTHOSE ADOPTIONS
WHICH ARE HANDLED BY THE PRIVATE.
SCHOOL LICENSE AGENCIES I HAVE
KATHY SUNDERLAND.
HERE IS SUPPORT SIGNALING PARTLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SUNDERLAND WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
PLEASE TO BE THE SPONSOR OF THE
LEGISLATION.
AS THE AUTHOR NOTED THERE
CURRENT PROGRAM IS OPERATED BY
THE STATE BUT USING TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT FUNDS THAT
THE COUNTY SHIFT -- OVER TO THE
STATE AND YOU UNDER CONTRACT
BETWEEN ONE COUNTY AND THE STATE.
THIS -- ARRANGEMENT WAS ALWAYS
INTENDED TO BE TEMPORARY THERE'S
BEEN A WORK GROUP -- THAT WE'VE
BEEN -- TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THE UNFINISHED BUSINESS
OF THAT GROUP -- WHAT HAPPENS
TODAY IS THAT COUNTIES ARE JUST
NOT ABLE TO CONTROL OR
ANTICIPATE THE EXPENDITURES --
FROM THE FROM THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM BECAUSE THE BILLS CAN BE
SUBMITTED FOR UP TO TWO YEARS
AFTER THE ADOPTIONS.
SO WE SUPPORT PART AND HAVE
WORKED WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR TOM
FAMILY SERVICES TO INSURE THAT
WILL CONTINUE IS A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM WITH THE STATE WIDE RATE.
BUT GIVING COUNTY IS THE ABILITY
TO AUTHORIZE THE PROGRAM AND
BETTER MANAGE TO THOSE FUNDS AS
WELL AS USE THE FUNDS MORE
EXPANSIVELY IF THERE ARE FUNDS
LEFT OVER.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WOODEN OKAY STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
OR SO I CAN JUST HEAR BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING CHRIS STONER MERTZ
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE AUTHOR AND C. W. D. A
TO GET THE LANGUAGE JUST RIGHT
OF COURSE OUR CONCERN IS JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
AS THE FUNDS ARE TRANSFERRED OUT
OF THE PARK FUND AND TO THE
COUNTIES.
THAT -- THE BILL REALLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE FUNDING FOR
THE PRIVATE ADOPTION NONPROFIT
ADOPTION AGENCIES.
IS OF C<c.cyan> CLEAR AN UP AND</c>
STATED IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN WHO ARE.
OF BROUGHT THROUGH THE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY.
WHO IS ALSO TRULY AN ADOPTION
AGENCY ARE ALSO FUNDED
CONSISTENTLY SO WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS A THAT LANGUAGE IS
PUT IN THE BILL?
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M JILL JACOBSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FAMILY
BUILDERS BY ADOPTION BASED IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION WE'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY AND
COOPERATIVELY WITH OF THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLYMAN COOLEY AND
MISSY WGA TO ACCOMPLISH THIS.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
YOU TO KNOW THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE PRIVATE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAN DO IT OPTIONS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
HOW WELFARE SYSTEMS IN THIS IN
THIS STATE WHICH IS KIND OF HARD
TO NAVIGATE AT TIMES -- NOT
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY.
IS COMFORTABLE GOING INTO A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY AND SO THE
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS OFFER JUST
A CHOICE ANOTHER CHOICE FOR
FAMILY AND I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT BUT THAT THIS IS JUST
A MOMENT TO ASK YOU TO NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU'RE.
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF BY SORRY
YEAH JILL JACOBS FAMILY BUILDERS
BY ADOPTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OKAY.
FROM COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CAN OFTEN OFFER A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF SERVICE AND
WE'VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
INNOVATIONS IN ADOPTION
INCLUDING.
CREATING ALL FAMILIES FOR OLDER
YOUTH WELCOMING L. G. B. T.
FAMILIES AND L. G. B. T. YOUTH
ARE TO PERMANENT SAYING.
SINGLE PARENTS.
IN THE OTHER THING IS THAT WHAT.
WE CAN WORK STATEWIDE COUNTIES
TEND TO WORK IT WITHIN THEIR
COUNTY WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES THE MOST OF THE
TIME THAT WORKS OUT WELL BUT
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T WORK OUT
WELL FOR FOR CERTAIN CHILDREN IN
FOR CERTAIN FAMILIES.
AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO WORK ACROSS
THE COUNTIES TO PROVIDE THE BEST.
POSSIBLE OPTIONS FOR CHILDREN I
WANT TO SAY I AM INTENT UPON
WORKING WITH THE PRIVATE
ADOPTION AGENCIES WITH A VERY
KEY ROLE.
AND I THINK THEY'VE GOT A LONG
AGENDA IS WHAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT YES SIR THIRTY
SECONDS WITH.
LET ME JUST CLOSE IN SAYING THAT
THE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE A CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
THE CHILDREN IN THE FAMILY.
Q..
KELLER IS REPRESENTING A SPIRIT
AND SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR WORK
MUST ON US.
LAURA RICHARDSON WITH QUEEN ANNE
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND SENSE OF
WE HAVE.
WELL I LIKE TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
AS THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
OUT OF HERE A TITLE HERE STONE.
STONE HERE BELT BELL HERE
JACKSON.
JACKSON HERE PAN WIENER.
OKAY GREAT SO.
WE'VE.
YEAH WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS. TO THIS BILL.
AND I VOTE THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU.
ALSO WE HAVE A MOTION -- THAT
HAS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR STROM.
AND THE RECOMMENDATION MOTION IS
TO DO PASSED THE SENATE%
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A TITLE I A TOTAL AYE STONE AYE
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
CINDY IS.
HIGH PAN WIENER.
THAT'S FOUR ZERO SO THE BALL IS
FOUR ZERO WHAT WILL GO AHEAD AND
GIVE THEM A CALL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
SO UP NEXT IS -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS ON EIGHTY SIX ITEM NUMBER.
THREE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
WHEN YOUR READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I PRESENT TO YOU AB SIX A BILL
WHICH CREATES THE BRANCH OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
INCREASING THE CAPACITY AND
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OF THE BOOK.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
FOR ALL EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROGRAMMING.
THIS GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE CAME
AS A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
SPEAKERS AT BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
THIS COMMISSION WORKED
DILIGENTLY FOR TWO YEARS AT
ASSESSING ALL ASPECTS OF THE
VERY COMPLEX EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION STRUCTURE WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH CULMINATED IN A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT.
THE VERY NATURE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION REQUIRES A
VARIETY OF STATE DEPARTMENTS.
IN MIXED MATHIS DELIVERY SYSTEM
OF CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL AND
THE INCLUSION OF A DIVERSE ARRAY
OF STAKEHOLDERS WITH PARTICULAR
NEEDS.
A STRONG UC SYSTEM JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER SEGMENT OF OUR EDUCATION
CAN ONLY EXIST WITH THE STRONG
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHICH
OPERATES. TO GUARANTEE OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS ARE TO YOU
ACHIEVING EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
EQUITY AS INTENDED.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CAN BE THE
GREATEST EQUALIZER THE
CALIFORNIA CAN PROVIDE FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
BRANCH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WILL ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE THE SOCIAL ECONOMICALLY
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY.
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMS IN AN
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
HERE WITH ME TO TO SPEAK MORE ON
THE MATTER REPRESENTING THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER IS
DIANA DOMINGUEZ.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME ON THIS ISSUE I AM
DIANNE ASSUMING GUYS WITH THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER THE
LARGEST NONPROFIT CHILD CARE AND
FAMILY SERVICES AGENCY IN
CALIFORNIA.
SERVING SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND NORTHERN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
WE KNOW THAT THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF A CHILD'S LIFE ARE
INCREDIBLY CRUCIAL TO THEIR
DEVELOPMENT.
CREATING A BRANCH OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WILL
SOLIDIFY CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENTS TO OUR CHILDREN
DURING THIS DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD
AND ALLOW ARE EASY EASY SYSTEM
TO WORK IN THE MOST COST
EFFICIENT AND PROGRAMMATIC LEE
AFFECTED WAY.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS COMPLEX
AND NOT ONLY OPERATES ACROSS THE
MULTITUDE OF STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO PROVIDES A
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM TO MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
NO OTHER EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA FACES THIS LEVEL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE FRAGMENTATION
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR FAMILIES
AND PROVIDERS TO NAVIGATE THE
SEAS SYSTEM.
MY CO DR MICHAEL NECK SERVED ON
THE ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION WHICH HARD EVIDENCE
OF CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES%
AND EASY PROVIDERS GETTING LOST
IN THE SYSTEM.
DID YOU ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES.
THE CREATION OF A BRANCH OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WILL
ILLUSTRATE CALIFORNIA'S
DEDICATION TO ITS YOUNGEST AND
MOST VULNERABLE LEARNERS.
AND ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM WORKS
BETTER FOR THEM.
DEVELOPING A SOLID EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION SYSTEM CHANGES AND
STRENGTHENS THE ENTIRE EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT MEANS MORE CHILDREN READY FOR
KINDERGARTEN AND THRIVING IN
SCHOOL IT MEANS MORE PARENTS YOU
CAN ENTER OR STAY IN THE WORK
FORCE AND UP LIFT THEIR FAMILIES
FROM POVERTY.
WE NEED A BRANCH OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A
STRONG IS THE SYSTEM AND REALIZE
ALL OF THESE BENEFITS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
UP STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION.
THE PERSON'S PERSONAL CLOSE HERE
ON BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SPELL.
THE NINE OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
THE BILL CAN WE HAVE A MOTION --
TO MOVE THE BILL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
Q. -- SO THE MOTION OF MADE IS
TO DO PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS US SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR TITLE I
TITLE IX STONE.
BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
ALL RIGHT PAN I'VE WINNER.
WINNER I AM.
FOUR ZERO COOL OKAY WHAT WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND LEAVE THIS UP.
BILL FOR ON CALL THE VOTE WAS.
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SO UP NEXT WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
PRESENTING ON AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB.
ONE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AND FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU ALL RECENT
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT POLICIES
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE RESOURCES AND DETENTION
FACILITIES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THE LIGHT OF THE RECENT
INCIDENTS WHERE CHILDREN HAVE
DIED OR BEEN A. B. C.'S FALL
UNDER THE CARE OF ICE.
THE US CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION AND WHILE IN THE
CUSTODY OF THE FEDERAL OFFICE OF
REFUGEE SAID RESETTLEMENT.
IT'S OUR PARA CURRENT SYSTEM IS
NOT DESIGNED TO SAFELY DETAIN
CHILDREN.
MOST RECENTLY DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WENT INTO NINE
FACILITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HOUSE UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS AND COMPILED
A REPORT ON THE CONDITIONS AND
SET KEY RECOMMENDATIONS.
A COMMON THREAD IS A
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGH NUMBER
OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES HOUSE IN THE MOST
RESPECT THE RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS
ALONG WITH THE LACK.
OF ADEQUATE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORTS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF HOUSING FOR THESE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT A NUMBER OF THEM
IN THE MEDIA.
ANY OF THESE FACILITIES MUST
HAVE A STATE LICENSE WHICH HAS A
UNIQUE TOOL FOR US TO LEVERAGE
YOUR SEPARATE FROM HOW I TOLD
HER HOUSE.
AND SO AB ONE SIXTY THREE AIMS
TO TRY TO LEVERAGE OUR STATE
LICENSE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
THESE CHILDREN TO TRY TO KEEP
THEM SAFE.
WE KNOW THAT THEIR ROAD HERE IS
TRAUMATIC OFTEN WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHILE THEY'RE HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO BE TRAUMATIZED THEM.
INTO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH
ME I HAVE EXPERTS WHO CAN SPEAK
MORE.
I TO THE NEED FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATIE
MATTHEWS AND I SERVE AS A STAFF
ATTORNEY INVESTIGATIONS UNIT I
DISABILITY RATES CALIFORNIA ALSO
KNOWN AS THE R. C. -- RELEVANT
AB ONE SIXTY THREE DEAR SEE HAS
DELVE DEEP INTO THE ISSUE
PROVIDING MUCH.
NEEDED SERVICES TO EMIGRATE
CHILDREN.
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
WHICH PROVIDES US WITH THE
BROADER STORY TAXESANY FACILITY
WHERE WE BELIEVE THERE MAY BE
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
SUBJECT TO ABUSE NEGLECT.
MY TEAM INITIATED LAST JULY THE
MONITORING OF ALL CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES.
THAT HOUSE CHILDREN IN THE
CUSTODY OF THE OFFICE OF REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT ALSO THERE IS --
ARE.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE YEAR WE
TOWARD NINE FACILITIES FROM SAN
DIEGO ALL THE WAY TO LOOK YOLO
COUNTY SPOKE TO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO CHILDREN.
AND INTERVIEWED CLINICIANS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS AT THESE
FACILITIES.
ALL BUT ONE OF THESE FACILITIES
ARE LICENSED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TWO WEEKS AGO DEAR SEE PUBLISHED
HER FINDINGS RECOMMENDATIONS IN
A SNAPSHOT PAPER ENTITLED THE
DETENTION OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN A REPORT YEARS HE MADE THREE
KEY FINDINGS REGARDING THE
TREATMENT OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES ALL WHICH ARE
PERTINENT.
TO EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THREE FIRST
YOUR SEATS COVER THAT CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HOUSE.
IN -- OURS MOST RESTRICTED
FACILITIES THE REASON FOR THIS
OVER POPULATION IN THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS IS THAT --
OURS POLICIES DETERMINE THAT A
CHILD CAN BE STEPPED UP.
FROM A LESS RESTRICTIVE FACILITY.
FOR EXITING SELF HARMING
BEHAVIOR THIS MEANS THAT
CHILDREN WAS SUICIDAL IDEATION --
AND PSYCHIATRIC DISABILITY NEEDS
CAN BE PLACED IN MORE
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS.
SOLELY BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISABILITY.
SECOND DRC FOUND THAT -- ARE
FAILS TO PROVIDE CHILDREN WITH
ITS CARE IT'S CARE WITH
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES.
NONE OF THE EIGHT FACILITIES
THAT ARE LICENSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
OFFER INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATIONAL
PLANS ALSO KNOWN AS IP'S. TO ANY
OF THEIR IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
WHEN ASKED WHETHER THERE WERE
CHILDREN WITH ANY LEARNING OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AT A
FACILITY ONE CLINICIAN RESPONDED
HONESTLY?
I DON'T KNOW.
IN ITS POLICIES -- ARE ONLY
PROVIDES A MINIMUM THE SIX HOURS
OF EDUCATION PER WEEK TO IS
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
THESE SIX HOURS ARE MEAGER AND
INADEQUATE WHEN COMPARED TO
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT REQUIRES AT
LEAST NINETEEN POINT TWO HOURS
PER WEEK. FOR THE CHILDREN WHO
ARE NOT IN FEDERAL CUSTODY.
IN THE COURSE OF OUR MONITORING
CLINICIANS AND SOCIAL WORKERS
EXPLAINED THAT -- OUR CHILDREN
DO NOT NEED AS ROBUST
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES AND
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN HAVE SUCH A
SHORT STAY.
THIS IS BOTH MISGUIDED AND NOT
TRUE.
MANY OF THE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
AND YOUR C. INTERVIEWED WERE
PLACED IN THESE -- OUR
FACILITIES FOR SIX MONTHS OR
LONGER.
THE ACTUAL CLASSROOMS THAT WE
WITNESSED WHERE IT IS ORGANIZE
WITH CHILDREN OF ALL AGES AND
ALL EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUNDS
PLACE TOGETHER.
THIRD DRC FOUNDED THAT LOWERS
ASSESSMENTS AND SERVICES FALL
SHORT.
COMPARED TO CALIFORNIA STANDARDS
WELL -- ARE DOES PROVIDE FOR
LIMITED ARRAY OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IT'S POLICY HAS LITTLE
SPECIFICITY.
AS TO BOTH THE SCOPE AND THE
DEATH OF THE SERVICES.
IN CONTRAST TO TITLE FIFTEEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS SCANTY REGULATIONS
UTILIZED FOR CHILDREN IN
JUVENILE DELINQUENCY PROCEEDINGS
PLACE IN JUVENILE HALL.
PLACE DO NOT HOLD AS MUCH MORE
IT IS EVEN MORE ABBASID AWARDS
AND POLICIES.
ALSO CHILDREN IN STATE -- FOSTER
CARE SYSTEMS -- RECEIVE FAR MORE
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENT AND CARE.
CURRENTLY -- OURS GUIDELINES ARE
LESS SPECIFIC AND DETAILED IN
CALIFORNIA STATE STANDARDS AND
THIS RAISES SERIOUS CONCERNS
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
REGULATORY GUIDANCE.
AND OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES RECEIVE BOTH THE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED.
AB ONE SIXTY THREE WITH A SYSTEM
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES TO
CHILDREN THAT DESPERATELY NEED
PROPER ASSESSMENT.
THE PORT AND TREATMENT.
AB ONE SIXTY THREE CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BETTER SERVICES
A BETTER ASSESSMENT.
IN ALL THESE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN DESERVE
BETTER.
AB ONE SIXTY THREE IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SUNDERLAND WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SIXTY THREE WE'VE WATCHED
WITH CONCERN AS STORIES OF
MALTREATMENT CONTINUE TO SERVICE
RELATED TO CILDREN IN THE
CUSTODY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ARE COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES DON'T HAVE FORMAL
JURISDICTION HERE BUT WE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE WELL BEING OF
THESE CHILDREN BOTH NOW AND IN
THE FUTURE. FOR THESE REASONS OR
SUPPORTING THIS EFFORT TO DO
WHAT WE CAN AS A STATE AND AS
COUNTIES. TO CONNECT TO THESE
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES THAT ARE
OPERATING HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WHERE THESE OLDER PLACE WITH
SERVICES THAT WE CAN OFFER TO
SUPPORT THESE CHILDREN WE THINK
THE LIAISON APPROACH IN THE BILL
MAKES SENSE AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS? TO
BROADEN THE GROUP OF WHO'S AT
THE TABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL TALKING TOGETHER THAT
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE IS ISSUED
SO THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR
ROLE CAN BE AND HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO HELP THESE CHILDREN.
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND CENTER BELL.
A YES UPPER SEVENTY QUESTION
TERMS OF I HEARD TO UNDERSTAND
OR AMENDMENTS TO BROADEN CAN YOU
SPEAK PERHAPS -- TO WHAT THE
AMENDMENT.
WHO WHO ARE ADDING ON?
WHERE IT EYES AT THE
STAKEHOLDERS THE WE HAVE A
LIAISON THAT IS SUPPOSED?
TO HELP A CONNECT -- SERVICES
AND SO AND WE EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL FATAL THERE'S
YES I BUT I BELIEVE THIS WAS A
CONVERSATION WITH THAT AB
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
OKAY THAT ASKED FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THAT WAS A BROADER
CONVERSATION AND TALKED ABOUT ON
THE TALK ABOUT GUIDANCE BEING.
ISSUED TO THE COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE WHAT
ARE APPROPRIATE ROLE AS AND DOT
THAT WERE NECESSARILY BRING NEW
SERVICES TO BEAR THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TODAY BUT HOW WE CAN BRING
WHAT WE HAVE TO BEAR TO HELP
THESE CHILDREN.
I APPRECIATE THAT I DIDN'T --
FIRST OF ALL I'M.
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I KNOW
THAT AND AS A PEDIATRICIAN IN
THE PEDIATRIC COMMUTERS --
EXTREME CONCERN ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THESE CHILDREN --
INTO THE PRESIDENT AMERICA K.
PEDIATRICS ACTUALLY AND VISIT
FACILITY.
AND ESSENTIALLY DECLARED A HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION AND I KNOW MANY
OTHER PEDIATRICIANS HAVE -- HAVE
SPOKEN OUT -- AND THOSE THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY HAD ACCESS OR VIN
OUR WORK AND THE LAST CALL TO
HELP OUT SOME THIS FACILITIES
HAVE CALLED OUT THESE ISSUES AS
WELL SO.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT --
THESE FOR IN CALIFORNIA I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE OTHER STATES BUT
LEAST HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE DO
WHAT WE CAN -- TO HELP --
SUPPORT -- THESE CHILDREN
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY ARE UNDER
I GUESS FEDERAL JURISDICTION SO
THAT LIMITS WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
DO BUT NOT.
CLEARLY THAT IS NOT WHAT IN MY
MIND AMERICA'S ABOUT IT'S REALLY
NOT WHAT CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRING FOR
THE SPELLING BEE HAPPY TO MOVE
IT APPROPRIATE TIME.
CENTRE BELL SELECT COMMENT OF
YES THE MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUSES
THE SENATE WE HAD A PRESENTATION.
ON THE SUBJECT OF THE EARLY
PRESENTATION I THINK IN FEBRUARY
AND I KNOW CENTER DRAWS THOSE.
THE LEGISLATION IS PROCEEDING AS
WELL BUT THE QUESTION I HAD --
FOR DO THE KIDS HAVE LAWYERS --
IS PART OF THE JOB WITH THE LAYS
ON IS TO CONNECTING WITH THE
LAWYERS RIGHT.
SO SO NORTHERN LAWYERS TO
REPRESENT.
I LOOK AT THIS IS LIKE THEY
SHOULD HAVE LEARNED JUST LIKE
KIDS IT DEPENDS THE COURT ORDERS.
OR THEY SHOULD HAVE LAWYERS WHO
THEY HAVE REPRESENTATION OF
THEIR RIGHTS.
AND YOU KNOW IF SOMEBODY NEEDS.
TO INFLICT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LEGAL PROCESSES THAT
SHOULD BE THE PART OF THE
PROCESS RIGHT.
SO I A YOU KNOW COULD YOU MAYBE.
TALK ABOUT THAT ISSUE AND I
THINK WE'RE SETTING IT UP.
THE RIGHT WAY WITH THE BILL BUT
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP ON THE
LEGAL LEGAL QUESTION I WOULD SAY
JUST FOR MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
GOING TO THESE DIFFERENT
FACILITIES -- BOTH IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IT
DEPENDED ON THE ACTUAL PLEASE WE
WENT TO SO THERE ARE SOME --
FACILITY SECURE FACILITIES OR
REGULAR FACILITIES WHERE YOU
WOULD SPEAK TO KIDS WHO SAID --
ABSOLUTELY THERE'S DEFINITELY AN
ATTORNEY -- WHO COMES HERE
WEEKLY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
UPDATED ON WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEIR CASE AND OTHER SITUATIONS
HE WOULD SAY -- I'VE BEEN MEN
I'VE BEEN REFERRED TO A SOCIAL
WORKER BUT I NEVER MET HER AND
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR NINE MONTHS
AND I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH MY CASE.
IT WAS IT WAS INCONSISTENT TO
FATALLY OKAY SO IS SO I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT'S DEFINITELY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PROCESS AND
SERVICES THAT COULD BE PROVIDED --
PERCENT AB ONE SIXTY THREE THAT
WOULD DEFINITELY RIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT STREAMLINED TO THE
EVERYONE KNOWS HAS ACCESS.
TO I MEAN USUALLY THE LOCAL
ORGANIZATION ORAL LAW SCHOOL
CLINIC WHO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
AT LEAST WHEN WE WENT TO VISIT
EACH INDIVIDUAL IN.
THE CENTER SKINNER AND I
REVIEWED SOME OF THE DEPENDENCY
COURT LEGAL.
ISSUES IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WERE ON SO WE SPELL
OF TIME ON US AND WE TRIED TO
BRING THE DEPENDS ACCORDS LEGAL
REPRESENTATION UP TO SNUFF.
AT YOU KNOW BECAUSE THEY HAD
SUCH A HIGH -- CASELOAD YOU KNOW
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE.
THIS IS A SIMILAR KIND OF THE
ISSUE AND I AM.
YOU KNOW I KNOW WE PUT MONEY
INTO IMMIGRATION LAWYERS BUT I
THINK THESE.
KIDS IS SPECIALLY SHOULD'VE
ORDERS.
OR SOMEBODY TO REPRESENT --
SOMEHOW.
AND YOU KNOW.
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO ENCOURAGE
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT WE CAN
DO THAT -- THAT WOULD HELP.
I LIKE TO KNOW CAN YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY.
DOING A SOME KIND OF ASSESSMENT
OF THAT ISSUE.
SO AT NIGHT.
WHEN WHEN WE STARTED THIS BILL
WE WERE MORE PRESCRIPTIVE WHERE
WE SAID THEY HAVE TO HAVE
LAWYERS MEN AND?
AND ASSESSMENT INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH -- AND SO IN THE PROCESS
YOU KNOW OF OF WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE ENDED UP WITH
THIS LIAISON WE HURT WE HEAR
STORIES ABOUT THAT THERE'S JUST
ENOUGH FIRE TYING THEM YOU CALL
THIS NUMBER OR LEGAL ASSISTANCE.
WE PUT MONEY ASIDE IN THE BUDGET
TO HELP UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
LEAGUE BUT LEGAL -- SERVICES AND
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THESE
CHILDREN BUT OFTENTIMES THE
DOLLARS AREN'T ALL BEING USED
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE GROUPS
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE KIDS
BUT WHETHER THE KID IS TO MENTAL
OR SIXTEEN YEARS ON THERE TO
GETTING THIS FIRE WHEN THEY SHOW
UP.
IN OUR CUSTODY THE THING THAT
THE BEST WAY TO DO IT TALLIES AT
THE LEAST I CAN MAKE SURE THAT
IT GOES BEYOND HIS THAT FLYER.
AND HOPEFULLY MAKE THE
CONNECTION TO THE LEGAL SERVICES
THAT ARE OUT THERE OR IF THERE
ARE NOT ENOUGH ATTORNEYS AND WE
WILL KNOW THAT THE PROBLEM TO
BUT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S REALLY LIMITED WHEN WE ASK
HAD BEEN TOLD AT TIMES.
BUT EVEN REYES.
ATTENTION TO THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE THIS LICENSE THAT WOULD
DELIVER CHECK BECAUSE THEY'LL
STOP SENDING OF KIDS AND THEN
THAT'S GOING TO BE EVEN WORSE I
GOING TO GO TO WORST PLACES AND
THERE MIGHT BE SOME TO DO THAT
BUT HE'S SAYING WELL MAYBE IF WE
DID THE RIGHT.
THING WE CAN ENCOURAGE OTHER
STATES TO FOLLOW OUR LEAD AD DO
THE RIGHT THING BY ALL THESE
KIDS ACROSS THE U. NOT TO SHARE
IN CALIFORNIA.
ON IT SO IT'S BEEN A REALLY
FRUSTRATING PROCESS AS AS I
THINKABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A TOOL AND WE SHOULD BE
LEVERAGING THAT SOMEWHERE I
DON'T PRETEND TO BE AN EXPERT AT
AS AN ATTORNEY AS A SOCIAL
WORKER I I KNOW HOW TO TEACH YOU.
MATH AND THAT'S IT RIGHT AND I
KNOW HOW TO VOTE AND STUFF BUT
IN TALKING TO THE EXPERTS.
THIS HAS BEEN THE BEST
COMPROMISE MOVING FORWARD TO AT
LEAST TRY TO DO IT BETTER I
THINK THROUGH THESE LIAISONS YOU
MIGHT DECIDE THAT WE NEED MORE
LATER.
BUT IT'S BEEN THE FIRST STEP --
IT IN IN THAT DIRECTION AND SO I
HAVE TO JUST TRUST AND THE
EXPERTS TELL ME THAT THAT THIS
IS A GOOD FOR STEPS TO GO TO FOR
THE FIRST HURDLE.
ARE YOU YEAH THE QUESTION I I
WAS THE ISSUE I WANTED TO RAISE.
I THINK WHEN WE START
RECOGNIZING THESE CHILDREN AS
HUMAN BEINGS.
ARE THAT'S THE FIRST STEP WE
NEED TO TAKE LAWYERS OF COURSE
THEY NEED LAWYERS EVERYONE.
WHO COMES INTO THIS COUNTRY IS
TECHNICALLY ENTITLED TO BE
REPRESENTED BY COUNSEL AND
WHATEVER THE GRIEVANCES ARE THAT?
ARE BEING PRESENTED TO THEM.
WHETHER BY THE GOVERNMENT OR
WHAT HAVE YOU AND I'M JUST
REMINDED OF THE DISCUSSION WE
HAD I CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER WHEN
IT WAS BUT A FEW YEARS AGO.
WHEN A FEDERAL JUDGE DETERMINED
THAT A THREE YEAR OLD WAS
CAPABLE OF REPRESENTING OUR SELF?
IN A YEAR -- AN IN IMMIGRATION
PROCEEDINGS.
IF WE'RE AT THAT POINT.
IT'S JUST THE START ISSUING A
GAG EITHER THOUGH THERE'S NO
DESCRIPTIVE WORD I CAN USE THEIR
BUT I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE.
AND AGAIN I THINK -- WHEN WE
START LOOKING AT THESE CHILDREN
AND THEIR PARENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AS HUMAN BEINGS LIKE
OURSELVES -- WE WILL HAVE COME A
LONG WAY BUT UNTIL THEN I YEAH.
I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO AND MOVES THE BILL.
SO DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NO OKAY A C. NONE OF WHICH YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA -- I WILL SAY THAT I GO
HOME REGULARLY AND I'M SURE THE
REST OF YOUR HERE AT HOME TO OUR
FOLKS ASKING US TO DO SOMETHING
DO ANYTHING.
OUR ALL MORTIFIED BY THE STORIES
THAT WERE SEEN -- AND
HEARTBROKEN -- AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I HOPE WE COMMIT TO THE FACT
THAT THIS IS JUST ONE TOOL IN
THE TOOL KIT AND WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO ADD MORE
TOOLS TO THE TOOLKIT FOR ALL OF
OUR KIDS OUT THERE.
THANK YOU.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN AND THEN THE SECOND
[inaudible]
ONE SENATOR JACKSON'S -- THE
RECOMMENDED MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AND
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
TITLE I THE TITLE AYE STONE.
STONE NO BELL.
WELL HI JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN.
AND I WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
IT'S FOUR FIFTY FIVE ONE IT'S
ABOUT. FIVE ONE AND THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO UP NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. -- TWO EIGHT THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE BILL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE STILL WILL
BE PRESENTED ON HIS BEHALF.
AND SO I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND
JUST GET A FRIENDLY REMINDER
THAT -- IT'S EIGHT PM AT AB
THREE LADY THREE MILLION FIVE
WITNESSES. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE AND BRINGS THAT WHILE FAR
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH OTHER PORTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA LAW RELEVAT TO TRY
AND SEE AN IMMUNIZATION.
THE BILL REMOVES THE DUPLICATIVE
REQUIREMENT AND FINANCIAL
PENALTIES REGARDING CHOI AND SEE
PLACE ON FAMILIES THAT QUALIFY
FOR CAL GRANT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IS JUST THE FOURTH ALL OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
AND KEVIN ELLIS ST -- THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WILL FOR
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS THE MORE
THEY KNOW MORE THAN ME ABOUT THE
BILL SO I WILL LET THEM TAKE
CHARGE THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU JUST GIVE OUR LOWER
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THE RESEARCH HAS SHOWN OVER THE
PERIOD OF TWO DECADES.
THAT MAKING.
POOR FAMILIES POOR -- DOESN'T
HELP THEIR CHILDREN GET TO
SCHOOL.
AND IT DOESN'T HELP THEIR
CHILDREN BE HEALTHY UNVACCINATED
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY SUPPORTS VACCINATIONS
AND SUPPORTS EDUCATING FAMILIES
ON HOW TO BECOME VACCINATED.
AND HOW TO MAINTAIN THE
VACCINATION DOCUMENT DOCUMENTS --
AND HOW TO SUPPORT THEIR KIDS TO
BE HEALTHY -- AS THEY ENTER INTO
PRESCHOOL AND SCHOOL WE THINK
THIS BILL HELPS TO ACHIEVE THAT
GOAL BY -- REFORMING THE
PENALTIES IN THE PROGRAM.
AND WITH THAT WE ASK FOR A BILL
THANK YOU.
KEVIN OTHER COALITION CALIFORNIA
WHAT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION WILL
ALSO SPONSORING THE BILL AND PAY
SO WITH THE BILL USED TO BE --
OFF TO CHILDREN WHO HAVE WOULD
ACTUALLY MEAN IZED COULD NOT GET
THE VERIFICATION TO ACCOUNTING
FOR SOME REASON.
AND THE BENEFITS WILL BE TO SO
FIVE THIRTY FIVE DOWN TO THREE
FIFTY FIVE A MONTH AND THAT WAS
DEVASTATING FOR MORE FAN WELL
MOST FAMILIES.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME UP STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED TO
THIS.
BILL PLEASE COME ON UP ST
.
GETTING A MANAGER.
ROB GROWS CLOSER ME HALF OF A
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY --
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE PROPOSAL AS
AMENDED WITH THE BILL I DO
APOLOGIZE OUR LETTER GOT IN LATE
WE GOT IT ON TUESDAY OF LAST
WEEK -- THE BILL HAS AN
EXCELLENT GOAL AND ONE THAT
RESONATES WELL FOR ME I WAS BORN
IN REAL AND AND GREW UP IN THE
PAST FIGHTS AND WE WALKED OR
TOOK THE BUS TO THE HOSPITAL --
SO IT'S ONE THAT ACTUALLY IS
KIND OF ODDLY ENOUGH HITTING ME
EMOTIONALLY A LITTLE BIT HERE --
SO WE COMPLETELY AGREE THE TEN
AND THE INTENT OF THE BILL
UNFORTUNATELY WE SUPPORTED THE
BILL AS INTRODUCED AND WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN WE
ARE UNFORTUNATELY AND AND AND
OPPOSE LAST MINUTE POSITION --
WE DO BELIEVE THAT -- ENSURING
THAT THOSE THAT ARE POVERTY ARE
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE CAL WORK
BENEFITS -- ARE ESSENTIAL BUT WE
UNFORTUNATELY BELIEVE THAT THE
VACCINATION SHOULD NOT BE TIED
TO THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY WE
THINK THE BILL LACKS THE
NECESSARY PROVISIONS PROTECTING
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS FROM UNDUE
PRESSURE. TO VACCINATE THEIR
CHILDREN EVEN THOUGH SUCH
VACCINATIONS MAY BE HARMFUL --
OR OR AREAS WAS THE NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LOOKS FOR
SPECIALIZATION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND THOSE ISSUES -- WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT IF YOU WERE TO
LOOK AT WHAT TWO SEVEN SEVEN
DEAD IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OF THIS
BILLS NOT COMPLETELY IN LINE
WITH THAT.
I SPECIFICALLY RELATING TO
COMPULSORY IMMUNIZATION FOR
SCHOOL TENANTS AND AS WELL AS A
CAL ORKS FUNDING FROM THE TANK
BLOCK GRANT -- IS POTENTIALLY
CAN BE HALTED. FOR A LACK OF
CONSCIOUS FOR RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTIONS ARE BEING INCLUDED --
LASTLY GOING BACK TO A TWO
EIGHTY THREE AND THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THE
BILL THE SCHEDULE WHICH IS
CURRENTLY MANDATED IN THE BILL
DOES NOT MERE THEY REQUIREMENTS
AND IT SENATE BILL.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN FOR TWENTY
FIFTEEN AS A BILL REQUIRES
ROTAVIRUS PNEUMOCOCCAL INFLUENCE
STILL AN INFLUENTIAL EXCUSE ME
AND HAVE A AND WE BELIEVE THAT
IS REFLECT WHAT WAS IN.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN AND ON OF THE
EXEMPTIONS GIVEN FOR HOME
SCHOOLERS IN THOSE CHILDREN WITH
A PIECE FOR EXAMPLE ACTUALLY
THANK YOU.
HI.
MY NAME IS CANDACE JOHNSON.
HI MY NAME IS CANDACE JOHNSON --
I WAS HERE LAST YEAR AND SPOKE
IN A POSITION OF AB.
ONE NINE NINE TWO I AM A CAL
WORKS OF CASH AID FOOD STAMPS
MEDICARE RECIPIENT IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- SO WHAT I
WANTED TO DO WAS HELP EVERYONE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
ACTUALLY -- APPLY FOR THESE
THINGS INSIDE THE OFFICE WITH
THE CASE WORKER SO DO YOU HAVE A
WORKING UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT
IS LIKE TO BE ME IN THAT
SITUATION.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS I GO IN FOR
THE INITIAL -- ELIGIBILITY
MEETING WHERE I SIT DOWN WITH
WHAT'S CALLED AN ELIGIBILITY
WORKER AND THEY DETERMINED BASED
ON MY INCOME.
WHAT I AM ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
FROM THE STATE?
THEY GO THROUGH A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THEN THEY GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY ASK ME IF I
HAVE MY CHILDREN'S VACCINATION
RECORDS RIGHT.
AND I LOOK AT THEM AND I SAY I
DO NOT BELIEVE IN VACCINATING MY
CHILDREN.
I DON'T LIKE TO USE THE BELIEVE
WORD BECAUSE IT'S OUR BELIEF
SYSTEM.
BUT I DON'T VACCINATE MY
CHILDREN RIGHT BASED OFF OF
RESEARCH THAT I'VE DONE.
SO THEN WHAT THEY DO IS THEY GO
INTO THE COMPUTER IN THE CLICK
OF A FEW TIMES AND PRINT OUT
THIS CALL BACKS NATION GOOD
CALLS FORM.
YOU'VE ALL BEEN GIVEN A COPY
[inaudible]
SO.
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY GIVE YOU A
LIST OF REASONS AS TO WHY YOU
DON'T HAVE THE DOCUMENTATION NOT
GOOD CAUSE FOR NOT VACCINATING?
GOOD CAUSE FOR NOT HAVING
DOCUMENTATION FOR NOT
VACCINATING.
THE VERY FIRST ONE SAYS YOU DO
NOT BELIEVE IN IMMUNIZING YOUR
CHILDREN THAT IS THE ONE THAT
I'VE ALWAYS CIRCLED AND HANDED
IT STRAIGHT BACK.
EVERY SIX MONTHS YOU HAVE TO
RECERTIFY.
IN PERSON YOU DON'T HAVE TO
pTHERE'S NO WAY THAT A PERSON
COULD NOT GET THIS TURNED INTO
THE OFFICE IS MY POINT.
SO THERE'S NO WAY THAT.
SOMEONE COULD BE.
HAVE THEIR BENEFITS DEDUCTED
BECAUSE OF LACK OF THE FORM
BECAUSE HEY PRINT IT RIGHT THEN
AND THERE IN FRONT OF YOU WHEN
YOU'RE SITTING IN THE OFFICE
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU CAN MAKE
IT OUT OF THE OFFICE WITHOUT
HAVING DONE THIS -- AND SO.
IF SO IF I IN SIX MONTHS GO BACK
TO RECERTIFY FOR MY BENEFITS I'M
GONNA GET DOCKED FIFTY DOLLARS
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE IN
VACCINATING MY CHILDREN.
WHEN VACCINATING MY CHILDREN HAS
ZERO TO DO WITH HOW MUCH INCOME
I HAVE OR WHAT MY BILLS COST?
SO MY CHILDREN VACCINATIONS THAT
IT SHOULD NEVER BE ON THE TABLE
AS A DETERMINING FACTOR OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR AID EVER.
IS MY POINT -- WHETHER OR NOT MY
CHILDREN ARE VACCINATED THEY
STILL NEED TO EAT.
WHETHER OR NOT MY CHILDREN
VACCINATED I STILL NEED TO BUY
THE BOOK BAGS CLOTHES FOR SCHOOL
PUT GAS IN THE CAR.
ALL THOSE THINGS SO -- YOU KNOW
INFANT IT CITES A STUDY IN THERE
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR ON
THE TH.
ON PAGE.
SEVEN SAYS THE STUDY.
FOUND THE UNVACCINATED CHILDREN
THOSE MISSING ALL ROUTINE
VACCINES TENDED TO BE WHITE.
HAVE A MOTHER WHO WAS MARRIED
AND HAD A COLLEGE DEGREE LIVE IN
A HOUSEHOLD WITH AN INCOME OF
OVER SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
HAVE PARENTS WHO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT THESE VACCINES.
RIGHT BEFORE THAT IT SAYS.
UP UNDER VACCINATED NOT
UNVACCINATED UNDER VACCINATED.
CHILDREN MISSING ONE OR MORE
ROUTINE VACCINES TENDED TO BE
BLACK HOW YOUNG UNMARRIED MOTHER
WHO DID NOT HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
AND LIVE IN A HOUSEHOLD NEAR THE
POVERTY LEVEL.
BUT THEY DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THE
PERSON THAT FALLS UNDER BOTH
BRACKETS ME I LIVE UNDER THE
POVERTY LEVEL I AM A WHITE WOMAN
WHO IS MARRIED.
WITH SOME COLLEGE EDUCATION BUT
I CHOOSE NOT TO VACCINATE MY
KIDS IT'S NOT BECAUSE I CAN'T
GET TO THE DOCTOR.
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN I GET TO THE
DOCTOR AND STILL TELLING THAT
DOCTOR NO I'M NOT BACK STATING
MY KIDS [inaudible]SO.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT I HAVE
WITH IT.
BECAUSE SIX MONTHS FROM NOW I'M
GONNA BE DOCKED FIFTY BUCKS
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE IN
VACCINATING MY KIDS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY -- DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL -- IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME TERRY
ROURKE TIONAL VACCINE
INFORMATION CENTER NATIONAL --
NATIVE CALIFORNIAN HAND
SURVIVING PARENT OF A VACCINE
INJURED CHILD IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE WHEN WE USED TO
USE THE PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE.
MY PHYSICIANS REFUSE TO GIVE MY
SON ADDITIONAL VACCINES
[inaudible]
WE OPPOSE.
IN THE WE IN THE ICY OPPOSES
THIS BILL BECAUSE PERSONAL
BELIEF.
HAS BEEN ELIMINATED.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE NOW WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
JUST FOR THE RECORD COULD YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION I'M
SORRY TERRY WORK NATIONAL
VACCINE INFORMATION CENTER.
I'M THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF
ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THREE NINE OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE BILL.
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION THAT OFTEN
WOULD YOU LOOK WHICH TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE ON BEHALF OF A FAMILY
MEMBER SURE.
I YES I JUST WANTED A THANKED
ARE PEOPLE I CAN'T JUSTIFY FOR
AND AGAINST THE BILL -- I'VE
BEEN INFORMED THAT THE BILL SAYS
THAT THE ME.
I THE THAT THEY MAY PAY THE
FIFTY DOLLARS SAID THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THERE WILL
BE A CHARGE OF ANY SORT.
I'D SAY THEY WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR THAT IS IN CHANGE HIMSELF
TO ME.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
CENTER PAN AND THAT MOTION IS
RECOMMENDED MOTION IS TO DO
PASSED SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
RICARDO.
I A TOTAL AYE STONE.
STONE NO BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE.
PAN ALL RIGHT PAN AYE WIENER
RIGHT WIENER I FIVE ONE SO THE
VOTE IS FIVE ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A GIVEN THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM I'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP
THE CONSENT ITEMS.
AND ON CONSENT WE HAVE AGENDA
ITEM ELEVEN AB NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
TWELVE AB ONE ZERO ZERO ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
HAVE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
BY A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN A
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
COMMITTEE AND AGENDA ITEM
FOURTEEN A. B.. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
AND SEPARATE.
SOME LITTLE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN AND SECTOR TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HELLO HI A TITLE AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL BELL AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HI.
OKAY DOUBLE IS SIX ZERO FOR THE
CONSENT ITEMS.
AND THOSE ARE ALL OUT.
OKAY UP NEXT AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
SIX AND OF YOUR PRESENT IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY ON
AB THREE TO FOUR PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO START.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB THREE
TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP STANDARDIZED EFFECTIVE
IMMEASURABLE GUIDELINES FOR THE
USE OF CURRENT AB TWO TWELVE
FUNDS.
AB TWO TWELVE IS A BILL BY DION
ERIN -- ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
THAT SET ASIDE ANNUAL FUNDS TO
IMPROVE THE RETENTION OF CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS.
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BILL
INCORPORATES THESE GUIDELINES
FOR THE NEW HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION.
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANTS
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER EXISTING AB TWO TWELVE
FUNDS ARE NOT HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS EVEN THOUGH THE TWO
FUNDS HAVE THE SAME PURPOSE.
AB THREE TWENTY FOUR SIMPLY LINK
THE EXISTING AB TWO TWELVE FUNDS
TO THE SAME GUIDELINES OUTLINED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
I ASK FOR YOUR I WROTE I HAVE
SENT HOME MY SUPPORT YEAH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
UP AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION POSITION THANKS.
HI DIANA DOMINGUEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
AND THE CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT NOW SEEN OKAY DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
XENON OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS BILL DOES
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
SO ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WILL
MAKE IT REALLY EASY I SIMPLY US
ROTH.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR.
DR PAN AND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL --
TITLE.
I TITLE I ASKED HIM STONE HI
BILL.
DEL AYE JACKSON [inaudible]
PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER RIGHT WIENER I
FIVE BY. FIVE ZERO SENATOR
PROJECTS.
SO THE BO IS FIVE ZERO AND WE
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON A CALL TO
ALLOW ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
HAVE A GOOD EVENING.
SEVEN AND HERE PRESENT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
THANK YOU -- AND HE WILL BE
PRESENTED ON A. B..
FOUR TO SIX I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE FREE BEFORE
TWENTY SIX IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE ENACT A REQUIREMENT
THAT I HSS APPLICANTS MUST
SUBMIT A STATEMENT FROM MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL THAT THEY NEED IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THE FORMER IS REQUIRED TO BE
CONSIDERED AS ONE INDICATOR OF
THE INDIVIDUALS NEED -- AND NOT
THE SOLE DETERMINING FACTOR
UNFORTUNATELY THIS REQUIREMENT
HAS ACTED AS A BARRIER.
ATTACK APPLICANTS STARK DOCTORS
CAN CHARGE OF TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE FORM AT
AS IT IS NOT A MEDICAL SERVICE
AND IS NOT COVERED BY MEDICARE --
A BEFORE TWENTY SIX WOULD REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT APPLICANTS
SUBMIT THE FORM INDICATING THEIR
NEED AND CLARIFY THAT A
REDUCTION IN HOURS CAN ONLY
OCCUR WHEN A VERIFICATION OF
CHANGE IS JUSTIFIED.
I HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THE
BILL'S KEVIN IT'S FUNNY AND WITH
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION.
GOOD EVENING KEVIN AS THE CHORUS
IN CALIFORNIA WILL FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS -- WE'VE WITH
PLEASING THIS BILL BECAUSE I'VE
HAD A NUMBER OF CLIENTS OF
COMING COMPLAIN TO ME THAT THE
DOCTORS ARE CHARGING.
IN THIS FORMERLY DOESN'T HAVE
ANY MEANING FOR REASON.
AND WHEN THE BILL PROVIDES THAT
WE WORK WITH THE PIPE AND TRY TO
COME UP WITH ALTERNATIVE VERSION.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD BE
JUST THE BOXY.
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME UP AND
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SUNDERLAND AT THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WE'VE HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL BUT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REMOVE THE CONCERNS BASED ON THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND WILL BE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
GOING FORTH WE REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR SPONSOR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE FORM CAN
CONTINUE TO BE USED WHILE WE
WORK ON THE ALTERNATIVE THAT
MISTRESS LANE IN MENTION.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- ECHO
IN THE COMMENTS THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER AWESOME MOVING FROM A
CONCERNS TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
I'M WITH THE COMMITMENTS AND
THANK EVERYONE -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
AND OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
SEEN UNDER WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU -- AND SOME NUMBERS
AND AS APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE
BILL FORD -- CERTAINLY -- GREEN
MEANT THAT THE PRESS MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY THE ONE PART I WAS
READING ANALYSIS I JUST LIKE
CLAIRE FINALIST IN CARE OF AND
AMENDMENTS IS THAT -- THEY DID
MENTION THAT I GUESS.
PRIOR TO HAVING THE MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION WHICH WAS IMPOSED --
THAT -- YOU HAD SOCIAL WORKERS
EACH COUNTY COME UP.
WITH THE EVALUATION BUT THERE
WAS ACTUALLY VERY ATION FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY SO.
I DON'T KNOW IT.
SO I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER FIND WE
TAKE AWAY THE MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION BUT IS THERE SOME
SORT OF STAND.
AS I I GUESS OF QUESTION IS IS
THAT ARE WE GOING TO GO BACK TO
A SITUATION WHERE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES USE HAVE DIFFERENT
STANDARDS OR IS THERE SOME
EFFORT AT TRYING.
TO AS OF A MORE CONSISTENT
STANDARD ACROSS COUNTY SO YOU
TAKE WEIGHT CLASS BECAUSE
MEDICAL CERTIFICATION REQUIRED A
CERTAIN YOU KNOW STANDARD.
ANDSEEM LIKE BEFORE BASED ON BY
RENDON NOW SISTER WAS SOME MORE
VARIATION WHICH EACH COUNTIES
THAT THE SHOW'S STANDARD FOR
THEIR OWN SOCIAL WORKER SO I
KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME EFFORT AT
FEATURE THAT WILL YOU T. ONE WAY
ONE COUNTY A DIFFERENT WAY THAN
OTHER COUNTY CELL I DON'T KNOW
THAT.
THAT'S BEEN ADDRESSED OR NOT.
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION WE WORKING WITH THE
KERN IS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS CONSISTENCY TO OF THE
STATE.
ALL RIGHT IN IT AT A FIGURE TO
THE SAUCE YOU KNOW I THINK YOUR
COMMITMENT TO TO WORK ON THAT.
RIGHT IT'S I JUST WANT TO BE
SURE THAT -- WE HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY SO WE DON'T HAVE A
LARGE VARIATION COUNTY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OUR WOULD YOU LIKE TO I THANK
YOU RESPECT A REQUEST AND I'VE.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY
SENATOR PELL ON AB FOUR TO SIX
AND THAT MOTION THE RECOMMENDED
MOTIONS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RICARDO.
I A TOTAL AYE STONE.
STONE HI BEL.
BEL AYE JACKSON.
PAN ALL RIGHT HAND HI WINNER.
WIENER HI BUT SO THE BILL IS
FIVE ZERO WE WILL BE A PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL JUST TO ALLOW THE
COMPETING MEMBERS TO PHONE SIX
OKAY AND THEN I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
A COUPLE OF OTHER BILL. TO
PRESENT YOU HAVE AGENDA ITEM.
EIGHT THEY'RE ALL GREAT AND AN
AGENDA ITEM.
NINE AND TEN A GENDER NIGHT
ITEMS TEN IN LIGHT THE AYE IN
LIGHT OF THE ARE A NUMBER OF THE
TERM AS GOOD AS QUICKLY AS AS I
CAN AND AS YOU.
DESIRE MADAM CHAIR -- AN AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TEN HAS BIPARTISAN.
NUMBER EIGHT DENNIS OKAY.
NUMBER EIGHT HAS A JULY ONE
THREE HAS PRETTY MUCH RIGHT.
WELL -- ESSENTIALLY AB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR WILL ESTABLISH A TWO
YEAR PILOT PROJECT PROJECT
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO
FOSTER AND KINSHIP.
CARE GIVERS.
PROPOSED PLACEMENT COACHING THIS
pCARE GIVERS ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND AND MEET THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN PLACED IN OUR HOME --
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN BEHALF
OF AB SEVEN THIRTY FOURS
MICHELLE EVANS WHO CAN ANSWER WE
CAN ALSO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
THANKS MICHELLE EVANS I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I HELPED DEVELOP THIS POLICY AS
HARD AS I LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC
POLICY CLINIC LAST YEAR WITH A
MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW.
AND I'M A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WITH JENNIFER REX ROAD FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE CARE
GIVERS. EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
FOURTH IS A CRITICAL NEED
FURTHERING THE AIMS AND GOALS OF
THE C. C. R..
AND SUPPORTING FAMILIES YOU HOLD
THE BURDEN OF THE CHILDREN PLACE
IN THEIR HOMES AND REALLY AND
THAT'S WE COUNT ON TO MAKE THE
C. C. R. AND BE SUCCESSFUL AND I
URGE OUR AYE VOTE AND IN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE CARRY SEVEN
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
TWENTY GOT IT WILL BE HAVE THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AMEND WE'VE BEEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
OKAY ARE.
BUT YOU WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
WITH I'M SORRY QUESTIONS THE
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NO OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STONE ON THAT MOTION THE
RECOMMENDED MOTION IS DUE PASSED
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL A TITLE I TITLE AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
PAN.
CAN I WINNER WIENER I ZERO THE
BILL IS [inaudible]
FIVE ZERO GREAT.
I JUST. FIFTY WHEN A CHILD IS
FOUND TO BE WITHIN THE
DEPENDENCY JURISDICTION OF THE
JUVENILE COURT THE STATE UNDER
TAKES RESPONSIBILITY.
AT TO MAKE ALL SIGNIFICANT
PARENTAL DECISIONS FOR A CHILD.
JUDGES PLAY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS HOWEVER HIGH
CASELOADS CAN BECOME A BARRIER
TO GETTING TO KNOW EACH CHILD IN
OBTAINING THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION. TO ACT IN THEIR
BEST INTEREST AB FIFTY NINE WILL
REQUIRE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
CONDUCT A STUDY AN APPROPRIATE
CASE THAT STANDARDS FOR JUDGES
TO ADJUDICATE.
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
IDENTIFY WAYS TO REDUCE WORKLOAD
AND EXPEDITE CASE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ARE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING LIVE -- YES WE DO
[inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible] FOR FOR
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THREE NINE OKAY THIS BILL DOES
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NOT SEEN NONE.
OF WHICH LIKE CLOSE I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IPHONE ALL RIGHT AND
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
STONE.
AND THAT -- RECOMMENDED MOTION
IS TO PASS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY CAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL RICARDO I RETIRED I STONE
BY STONE I BELL.
BELL AYE JACKSON.
PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO ON AGENDA
ITEM NINE AND WE'LL PLACE THAT
BILL ON CALL.
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
THE BILL ALSO HAS BY FAR GREATER
SUPPORT.
AND FINALLY MADAM CHAIR THIS IS
A BEEN A BILL I'VE WORKED ON FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS YOU ALL A VOTE
ON IT -- SEVERAL TIMES LOOKING
FOR TODAY TODAY GOVERNOR NEWSOME
ASSIGNING THE BILL AT THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN FACING HOMELESSNESS
IN AMERICA'S AND AN ALL TIME
HIGH.
A. B. -- NINE SIXTY WILL
LEMONADE THE DISINCENTIVE TO
REFUSE OR ENTER AT TEMPORARY
HOUSING ASSISTANCE CURRENT LAW
ONLY ALLOWS PERMANENT HOUSING
ASSISTANCE TO BE USED A
COMMERCIAL SETTING SHELTER WITH
A PERSON IS IN THE BUSINESS OF
RUNNING PROPERTY.
A BEING NINE SIXTY WILL OPPERMAN
HOUSING SYSTEM ASSISTANCE TO BE
USED TOWARDS SHARED HOUSING
SENTENCE [inaudible]
SETTINGS.
THIS BILL ALSO PERMIT COUNTIES
TO WAIVE THE SIXTEEN DAY LIMIT
FOR IT ASSISTANCE AN AUTHORIZED
ADDITIONAL DAYS FOR TRANSITION
SHOULD A FAMILY FIND HOUSING --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RESPECT
HERE BECAUSE MY ABOUT MY MY
WITNESSES ARE HERE ALSO.
THAT'S ABOUT THE WITH A WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
THE SIZING HOW IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY THIS ISSUE IS AND HAS
BEEN OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL AND STAYING WITH IT AND WE
ARE DR -- THEN KEVIN AS THE
CHORUS CHORUS OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
DIDDLE.
THANK THE WITNESSES FOR
WITNESSES INTO FOUR PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION YEAH
THESE ARE REALLY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
CANDACE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
PEOPLE THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP.
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GREAT DO WE HAVE.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
VIENEN OKAY OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU AND I WHAT I
WOULD LIKE AS SENATOR STONE'S
REMARK ABOUT BEING A GREAT BILLS
PART.
GREAT TO THANK YOU.
CORD AS WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STONE AND THE
RECOMMENDED MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS ASPECT
TAKING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FOR
TITLE I RETIRED A AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL BELL AYE JACKSON
PAN HI CAN I WIENER.
WIENER HIGH FIVES.
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND WILL
PLACE THIS BILL ON CALL -- ON
CALL YES SORRY IT'S LATE.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS YES THANK
YOU -- I THINK.
WHAT WITH WHAT THE [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH.
AB.
EIGHT NINETEEN AND THAT
RECOMMENDED MOTION MOTION WAS
MADE BY SENATOR FASTER OWN THE
RECOMMENDED MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE.
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
RICARDO I RETIRED A AYE STONE.
STONE AYE BELL BELL AYE JACKSON
JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE SIX SO THE BILL IS
SIX ZERO AND AGENDA ITEM ONE IS
OUT.
GO ON A TRIP -- AGENDA ITEM.
TO YEAH YEAH SURE OKAY WE'RE
STILL GONNA. FIFTEEN CONSIDER TO
THE BUT HERE OKAY.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP --
OPEN CALL [inaudible]
AND OF MARK PLEASE PLEASE CALL
AND FILE ITEM TO AB THIRTEEN OH
ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR VOTES BY HAND.
PAN AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
SIX THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO ON
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
THERE'S NO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM THREE AB SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAY AS THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS -- THE
CHAIR BOTH SIDE ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
STONE.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH.
FIVE ZERO THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
ONE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM -- SIX A. B. THREE
TWENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY.
THE MOTION IS DEEP PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON.
JACKSON HI.
SIX SEARCH APPROACH IS SIX ZERO
AND THE BILL IS OUT.
BY LET HIM SEVEN A. B. FOR
TWENTY SIX MAIENSCHEIN.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE CHAIR BOTH BY
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI SIX THE BILL IS SIX
ZERO AN AGENDA ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
BUILT BY A BEFORE TWENTY SIX THE
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER -- EIGHT AB. SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BOATS HI
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE SIX THE BILL IS SIX
ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NINE AB FIVE OR EIGHT
FIFTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JACKSON.
JACKSON I SIX THE BILL IS SIX
ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM.
TEN AB NINE SIXTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CHAIR VOTES HI JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH SIX THE BILL IS SIX
THERE ON THAT BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
THOSE [inaudible]
YOU COME [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
UHHUH UHHUH [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH
[inaudible]
WELCOME ASSEMBLY BOTH OF YOU.
HERE TO PRESENT LAST BILL AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB FORTINO.
THREE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
NO IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
I'M HERE 2% OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN OH THREE WHICH WOULD
CORRECTED OVERSIGHT AND STATE
LAW TO ENSURE THAT DEEPLY
IMPOVERISHED INDIVIDUALS.
CAN APPLY FOR CRITICAL RESOURCES
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND IS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THAT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED.
IN THE ANALYSIS MADAM CHAIR WHEN
THE CALIFORNIA WORK OPPORTUNITY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR KIDS PROGRAM
ALSO KNOWN AS CAL WORKS.
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THE LEGISLATURE SOUGHT TO
ENSURE THAT CAL WORKS PARENTS
MOSTLY WOMEN.
WHO HAD REACHED THEIR TIME
ALLOTTED FOR ASSISTANCE FORTY
EIGHT MONTHS BUT ARE STILL
RECEIVING CO WORK THROUGH THEIR
CHILDREN?
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR COUNTY
GENERAL ASSISTANCE.
HOWEVER IF THE CHILDREN ARE
UNDER EIGHTEEN AND REMOVED FROM
THE CUSTODY OF THE PARENT OFTEN
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN FOSTER CARE
OR WITH A RELATIVE.
THE PARENT MUST OFTEN BE.
MAY OFTEN BE IN DOES AND
DESTITUTE -- BUT THEY ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR GENERAL ASSISTANCE.
AB FORTINO THREE WILL CORRECT IN
OVERSIGHT IN THE LAW TO ENSURE
THAT DEEPENING PARSON THE
VISUALS.
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR GENERAL
ASSISTANCE THERE BY ALLOWING
THEM TO ACCESS CRITICAL
RESOURCES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THE CRITICAL ISSUES WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS.
REGARDING COST PRESSURES TO OUR
COUNTIES WE HAVE JESSICA BARTH
LOW WITH THE WESTERN CENTER OF
LAW AND POVERTY AND KEVIN.
AS AS LENDING.
WITH THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL WHICH AS THE
AUTHOR HAS REALLY -- A DONE A
GOOD JOB IN EXPLAINING WILL HELP
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO.
ARE IN DIRE NEED HAVE ZERO
INCOME AND DON'T HAVE KIDS KIDS
IN THEIR HOME ARE NOT DENIED.
THE BECAUSE THEIR PURPORTED TO
HAVE KIDS IN THEIR OWN.
WE BELIEVE THAT -- THE COMMITTEE
AND NOW SAYS AN IMMENSE -- HELP
STRENGTHEN THE BILL AND WE ARE
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION AS THE BILL OVES
FORWARD.
THANK YOU -- I BUILT.
YEAH KEVIN AS THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WHAT PARTS ARE GONNA
DITIONS WELL SUPPORT SPONSORS
BUILT OVER TO HELP WOMEN.
WERE HAVING SEVERE PROBLEMS --
AND WILL IT WILL IT WILL WORKING
WITH OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING IS OKAY THANK
YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE COME UP STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION --
SIDE.
THE FOR TO COME UP AND GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY SORRY.
TESTING HERE OUT OF CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
CALIFORNIA -- WE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL BECAUSE OF FISCAL CONCERNS
THAT I OUTLINED BUT FIRST I JUST
ALSO WANT TO THINK THE OFF THEIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THERE IS
ALL OF THE POLICY CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE REYES WITH THE BILL.
I'M ON THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS
GENERAL ASSISTANCE IS ENTIRELY A
COUNTY FUNDED UNDERSTAND COUNTY
FUNDED COUNTIES ALSO RESPONSIBLE
FOR DETERMINING.
A BENEFIT LEVELS IN ELIGIBILITY --
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THIS BILL
WOULD IMPOSE A STATEWIDE MANDATE
FOR A SPECIFIC POPULATION BUT
PROVIDE NO STATE FUNDING FOR
THAT EXPANSION OF LOCAL SERVICES.
I'M HOWEVER SYMPATHETIC --
POPULATION MIGHT BE THE MOST
OPPOSE THE PRESIDENT THIS BILL
WOULD SET OF EXPANDING GENERAL
ASSISTANCE ELIGIBILITY WITHOUT
ANY STATE FUNDING -- ALL THAT
SAID WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS I NEVER
READ THE CONCEPTUAL AGREEMENTS --
THAT WOULD INCLUDE LANGUAGE TO
MAKE THIS REQUIREMENT SUBJECT TO
THE PREPARATION.
I'M WERE ABLE TO WORK THAT ALL
THE WAY OUT PRIOR TO THIS
HEARING -- BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THAT WILL BE TAKEN IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I'M IN
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION AT THAT POINT THANK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY'S UNDERLING WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS ARE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION AND VIDEO.
AT THIRTY IS WHEN THANK AT THE
OFF THEIR FOR WORKING TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES AND CONCERNS -- YOU
KNOW I I PRETTY MUCH HAVE THE
SAME ISSUES AND AND CONCERNS AS
THE WE'RE ADDRESS TODAY AND BUT
THIS IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE AND
YOU KNOW I SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS
ON WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
AND SO -- HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
THE BILL TODAY TO HELP GET IT
OUT AND SO ONCE.
GREAT TO ANY QUESTION SIR --
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU WELL ONE I
WANT TO THINK -- OUR SPONSORS
THAT HAVE -- REALLY PUT THIS TO
LIGHT AS WELL AS THE OPPOSITION
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY
EVERYBODY AT THIS TABLE.
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO NEED HELP ARE ASSISTED.
AND THAT A LOOPHOLE DOES NOT
DEVIATE FROM THE REALITY THAT IF
YOU NEED GENERAL ASSISTANCE YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR IT
WHETHER OR NOT YOUR CHILD HAS
BEEN TAKEN AWAY IS IN CUSTODY.
IS IN A DIFFERENT SITUATION IF
YOU ARE A WOMAN WHO NEEDS HELP
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THAT HELP.
AND SO WE WANT TO COME TO THE
TABLE TOGETHER TO FIND THE
SOLUTIONS FOR THAT.
AND MOVE THE BILL -- MAY
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT AND AND
COME TO A RESOLUTION TO AT THE
END OF THE DAY HELP MORE
CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ON AND THAT RECOMMENDED MOTION
IS TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK CALDERON FOR TITLE I TITLE
III STONE.
BELL.
BELL I'D JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
WIENER I FIVE SIX SEVEN FIVE
ZERO THANK YOU THANKS AND
JUSTICE WRAPS UP OUR HEARING.
FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
EVENING WITH US [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY